how does it feel to be here in warsaw
for the first ever grand chess tour
health here in poland it feels great to
be back uh i played here relatively
recently um for the world rapid blitz
championship
and it was it was a lot colder it was
during the winter it was very hectic
because you know
we played every day like
six plus hours a day um but the city is
beautiful and it's good to be here and
uh hoping to improve a bit on
my last tournament which you know it was
nice to play in bucharest but my level
of play wasn't really there so i'm
hoping to improve a bit special feeling
is that i can play against vichy with
whom i was working for many many years
and now we are
let's say
arrivals is a
strong word but let's say that we will
play
[Music]
games very nice i played an event in
poland 22 years back this is a blizzard
well blitz championship
but this is very nice i've come to visit
my my seconds here
but to come and compete here in this
wonderful venue
it's going to be a very nice experience
it's a very nice feeling it's really a
dream come true for me i i have been
watching the the top players for the
last few years and
i'm thankful to have the opportunity to
face them on the chess board yeah it's a
very special feeling that actually
grandchild story is hard in warsaw in
poland you know i'm not quite used to
playing such strong events in poland so
it's a nice thing
oh yeah it's very nice i i like to be
part of this debuting event
i think i haven't played an event before
which was the
first time organized but i have been to
warsaw just uh quite recently for the
rapid blitz i was kind of sure that it's
going to be uh
well organized and i like rewards was
nice but this time at least it's a
little bit warmer than
than winter ride so it's uh it's nice
yeah i feel good i feel very privileged
here i'm very happy that they have uh
they decided to become part of grand
chester and they have a large tournament
here with some of the best players in
the world so uh
it's uh it's a good audition my first
time poland never played there before
and i'm very excited warso is
a great place it's a place where i've
played a zillion times
but rarely in the summer or in the
spring
so it's absolutely wonderful i had a
long walk in the old town yesterday and
he
loves it so much and so
i really enjoy being here it's very
amazing that i am invited in this
grandchild store
and
it's very big pleasure for me to play
against
such a top grandmasters and i'm very
excited i'm afraid all the time yeah
when coming to the granchester my films
are the same they had in bucharest or in
zagreb more or less led you
to you to be a victim in the tournament
and to be tortured until the very last
round
[Music]